chairman
Brussels will soon come with new European taxes
why because next generation EU
the so-called corona repair fund must be paid
why was this fund needed again
because the EU must grow
and why should the EU grow
because the huge budgets for bureaucracy
climate and the funds for southern Europe
should not go down
and why not
because the EU has to contract differently
and why is that not allowed
because then the EU loses power
but because of the higher interest it is
become even more expensive for the EU to borrow
so even more money has to go to Brussels
and guess who gets it from
in people's homes,
of course
and that's why new taxes are being introduced
chairman the billions of the next generation EU
have not even been picked up yet
let alone issued
time to quit the fund
before it's all too late